donc SS veulent pas se mettre aussi dans
la bah qu'ils arrêtent de s'intéresser à
des gamines voilà je désolé pour la
morale elle a pas temps mais ça c'est la
morale
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
la alors déjà je voudrais rappeler une
chose c'est que Sébastien c'est quand
même le premier plaignant c'est ça donc
c'est le premier à avoir déposé plainte
donc c'est la victime voilà et après
donc on a d'abord enfin il a d'abord
déposé plainte pour cyberhcèlement suite
à à des tweets exactement
après l'accusation de violle est arrivée
ouais c'est quand même très grave ah oui
donc là il avait toutes les
preuves de tentative d'extorsion en
bande organisé il est allé à la police
il a déposé plainte pour dénonciation
calomnieuse faut usage de faux et
tentative d'extorsion en bande organisée
en bande organisée c'est dire que il a
prévenu la police qu'il y aurait
d'autres plignantes derrière puisqu'il
avait toutes les preuves matérielles
voilà alors comment comment comment vit
ça bah voilà on comment comment ça s'est
passé c'est c'est Sébastien qui est venu
vous voir qui vous a dit il y a un
complot contre moi
alors non en fait c'est j'ai pas Twitter
je suis un peu cnecté des réseaux j'ai
que Instagram j'étais en shooting photo
et j'ai reçu des des messages de de
followers en fait bêtement et je suis
rentré le soir il m'a il m'a dit écoute
je comprends pas voilà
c'est presque on croit une blague au
début he une mauvaise blague et puis
voilà au début au début vous dites c'est
juste un truc sur Twitter ça va ça va
vite passer ça va vite s'estomper ou
bien vous sentez tout de suite que ça va
prendre une ampleur non c'est pas ça
c'est que quand on voit l'importance des
tweets on peut pas on peut pas laisser
faire ça c'estàdire que tout de suite
euh il y a du cyberhcèlement donc on le
dénonce on va à la police on dépose
clinte évidemment on peut pas laisser
n'importe qui tolérerait de telles
accusations ouis alors euh est-ce que
votre mari vous avez déjà parlé de de de
de de de de ce complot avant ou pas du
tout ou il l'a découvert comme vous ah
ben on l'a découvert ensemble ça ouais
vous avez déposé combien de
plaintes deux mais la deuxième est
rassemblée en faux usage de faux
tentative d'extorsion en bande organisée
et dénonciation calomneuse oui la
dénonciation calomieuse c'est contre une
des plaignantes Julie que nous avons
reçu voilà et quand vous dites que vous
avez découvert c'estàdire que il ne sait
pas lui qui pouvait lui en vouloir ah
pas du tout alors vous étiez vous étiez
avec lui au moment des faits euh euh
voilà au moment où il apprend tout ça
tout de suite qu vous il il apprend tout
ça oui oui on est ensemble en au début
on sentait que voilà il
allait il disait voilà c'est un complot
enfin vous et à un moment on sent que
plus ça dure et plus on a l'impression
que moralement ça le ça le ce qu'il
disait c'est que ça le touche vraiment
énormément mais Cyril si on vous porte
des accusations mensongère à votre
encontre Mo je dire de telles
accusations vous réagissez comment non
mais moi je vous dire ils ont dit que
j'avais
un bateau al j'en avais de ça a été un
drame non non mais non mais là
l'accusation qui lui est porté est quand
même grave c'est pas quelque chose à
prendre avec légèté très grave je sais
pas c'est donc évidemment comment il est
bah il est déjà anéanti
dévasté moi j'ai j'ai rencontré séastien
c'est quelqu'un de solaire qui se lève
le matin et toujours de bonne humeur là
j'ai quand on a quand on a appris ça Seb
m'a dit je vais vous dis si tu n'es pas
là n je me fous en l'air clairement mais
c'est c'est tellement grave on touche à
l'honneur d'un homme siriril non je
pense surtout qu'il a dit à ses enfants
aussi il a paré mais les enfants c'est
c'est déjà c'est horrible parce que T
tous les commentairire qu'on a pu lire
sur les réseaux c'est d'une violence je
me dis mes enfants ces enfantson on a
quatre enfants à deux qui lisent ça
c'est horrible alors moi je suis une
louve j'ai envie de protéger mon foyer
j'ai je je fais au mieux pour combattre
ça com fa comment vous fait pour comment
vous faites pour vivre actuellement
vous-même est-ce que les gens vous en
parlent tout le temps est-ce que ou
est-ce que voilà vous vous me faites
vraiment vous essayez de faire
abstraction alors les gens on a
énormément de messages de soutien ouis
moi je je m'efforce je je ne dors pas la
nuit je ne dors presque plus la nuit
parce que j'ai j'ai tellement je veille
sur Seb en fait j'ai tellement peur
qu' voilà je me réveille la nuit je
regarde s'il à côté de moi je suis sur
les nerfs donc
voilà comment on vit ça la question
c'est j'ai excuse excusez-moi je suis
non mais je même pas la question je
comprends c'est toute la journée vous
vivez qu'avec ça normalement c'est non
on peut pas vivre normalement on a
énormément de messages de soutien moi je
m'efforce à à répondre à chaque message
de soutien je prends le temps je ça me
prend du temps mais c'est tellement
important chaque personne qui prend le
temps d'écrire un long message voilà et
vous savez à chaque fois que je lui lis
un message il se m'a
pleuré ça c'est dur il vous dit quoi au
quotidien il me dit quoi au
quotidien qu'il est détruit qu'on a
touché à son honneur qui il se lève le
matin il pleure il se couche le soir il
pleure il est angoissé voilà on a
détruit un homme qu'est-ce que vous
voulez que je vous
dise il s'estexprimé hier sur BFM comm
on l'a vu euh il a décidé et vous avez
décidé vos avocats on annoncé
aujourd'hui saisir l'arcom euh donc le
gendarme de l'audiovisuel
pourquoi parce que ils ont diffusé
hier des pièces oui totalement fausses
ils étaient
prévenus et ils ont fait le choix de les
diffuser donc les avocats ont décidé de
saisir l'arcom tout simplement et je
pense sincèrement que ces pièces c'était
uniquement pour Sébastien je vous le
confirme oui donc voilà ah oui non mais
après après je sais que ils se sont vu
avant l'interview puisque l'interview a
été préparé avec
cé des communiquants les avocats et
Benjamin diomel puis que j'ai même je
crois que j'ai même des photos
d'ailleurs montrer que voilà ça a été ça
a été préparé hein voilà avec avec le
journaliste de BFM donc le journaliste
de BFM avait avait tout préparé donc
est-ce que c'est un il lui a fait un
coup
un coup dans le dos j'ai pas envie de de
commenter j'ai pas envie de donner mon
avis en tout cas vous avez saisi
exactement vous avez bien raison voilà
mais en tout cas vous avez saisi l'arcom
donc ça veut dire ce que ça veut
dire Nathalie je sais vous êtes en plus
vous êtes je conis un peu Nathalie
nathalie est tout le temps en train de
rigoler
de oui le CL le clown dans couple c'est
moi non mais c'est ça c'est vrai
et aujourd'hui vous êtes sûr et c'est
important pour no téléspectateurs que
vous le disiez vous êtes sûr que votre
Marie est innocent ah mais évidemment
deux choses déjà la première les preuves
que j'ai vu tellement accablante il y a
pas c'est voilà c'est il est innocent
après il y a le Sébastien que je connais
il y a le Sébastien que j'ai rencontré
l'homme qu'il est je sais que Sébastien
je l'ai dit à Gill il n'a jamais été
comme ça il n'est pas comme ça il ne
sera jamais comme ça donc je je connais
connais ses valeurs je connais ses
principes je sais qu'il est gentleman on
s'est rencontré il a on a pris le temps
il n'a jamais forcé aucune femme
d'ailleurs il ne pourrait pas forcer une
femme il n'a jamais violenté une
femme 5 d'accordord Sébastien il a
besoin de voir le plaisir dans les yeux
d'une femme il peut pas
ENF c'est non il est innocent donc
justethie on entend j'entends beaucoup
de gens de l'entourage Sébastien qui
disent on a des preuves accablantes euh
et c'est vrai que on a l'impression que
ces preuves chaque jour qui passe euh
est-ce que vous vous rendez compte que
c'est euh non c'est un supplice pour lui
s'il est innocent et que chaque jour qui
passe euh le fait qu'il soit plus qu'il
exerce plus son métier pour lui ça le
c'est le procès médiatique se met en
place tous les jours encore un peu plus
pourquoi les preuves ne sortent
pas on a l'impression que les avvez
depuis des semaines et que ça sort pas
mais oui j'aimerais bien que ça sorte
mais mais le problème c'est qu'il y a
une enquête en cours ça prend du temps
la police fait très bien son travail les
enquêteurs font très bien leur travail
ça prend du temps d'interroger de
rassembler mais les preuves sont là et
et voilà ça encore un peu de patience il
va mieux depuis qu'on a les preuve et
qu'on sait que que voilà les preuves
sont accablantes donc il commence à
prendre à reprendre du poil de la bête
on va dire c'est c'est l'épreuve la plus
dure de votre vie avec que vous avez sub
alors
lui il a connu la perte de ses parents
il a perdu sa maman sa maman est tombée
malade à 9 ans il a perdu sa maman à 10
ans et son papa à 20 ans quand vous
retrouvez à orphelin à 20 ans je peux
vous dire que ça c'est une épreuve moi
heureusement j'ai encore mes parents je
pense que là le drame que je vis c'est
une tempête je peux pas vous expliquer
c'est un cauchemar on dit on va se
réveiller mais lui il m'a quand même dit
que c'est presque
pire que d'avoir perdu ses parents
tellement c'est
mais c'est pas possible à 51 ans mais-
qui lui fait qu'est-ce qui lui fait le
le plus de
mal bah
qu'on qu'on puisse dire des choses
fausses sur lui totalement fausses c'est
c'est tout est faux qu'on puisse lui
donner moi j'ai j'ai lu des choses
horribles j'ai on a décrit un pervers
sexuel attendez mais c'est
grave j'ai envie d'hurler en fait
en tant que femme Nathalie est-ce que et
vous l'avez dit pour il y a aucune pour
vous il y a aucun doute il il est
innocent est-ce que vous vous êtes mise
à un moment aussi à la place de de de de
ces de ces ces jeunes femmes qui TM et
est-ce que vous avez essayé même pe-être
de les de les joindre de leur parler ou
pas du tout alors je je ne m'abaisserai
pas à ça com vous avez essayé de vous
mettre alors non j'ai essayé de voir
dans enfin avec l'équipe on a essayé de
de d'identifier la personne donc comme
tout le monde moi j'ai vu je me suis
aperçu qu'elle avait qu'elle m'avait
écrit sur Instagram déjà là j'ai trouvé
ça ah oui je crois que j'ai relu à deux
fois je me suis
dit je sais pas c'est c'est tellement
j'ai pas de mot en fait et après
l'équipe la connaissait puisqu'elle a
envoyer à plusieurs membres de l'équipe
des messages photos vidé
plutôt
voilà
d'accord quand vous l'entendez dire qui
lui a ruiné sa vie
elle lui a ruiné sa vie non quand vous
entendez oui ah il lui a ruiné sa vie
quand vous l'entendez dire ça sur notre
plateau vous dites vous dites quoi alors
je vais vous dire je moi je je je suis
féministe et je je défendrai toujours
une femme qui dit avoir subi des
violences viol je trouve que la parole
des femme est importante ça c'est sûr
mais parfois on affire à des mensonges
et là faut pas se tromper dans ce cas
présent c'est Sébastien la la victime
tout est mensonges elle vous a dit quoi
sur insta euh la première fois tu es
très
belle et la deuxième fois elle elle a dû
répondre à une story certainement
j'étais avec Sébastien et c'était
dommage je n'y suis pas alors moi j'ai
j'ai j'ai on peut bloquer accepter ou
voilà donc moi j'avais jamais accepté
donc c'est rester comme ça mais je me
suis dit quand même c'est
euh c'est bizarre aujourd'hui euh donc
il n'est plus sur énergie actuellement h
euh est-ce que il y a des gens du métier
qui l'ont déjà lâché ou pas du tout il a
un gros soutien ah non il a un gros
soutien ouais un gros gros soutien ah
oui oui oui ça c'est d'accord un gros
soutien
vraiment euh on va revenir donc sur sur
cette affaire racontez-nous alors ce qui
c'est s passé et avec les nouveaux
éléments qu'on a avec Gy alors le 23
juillet là de cette année une jeune
fille de 17 ans va au commissariat de
police déposer plainte commissariat de
peau déposer plainte pour viol et elle
cite son agresseur comme étant Frédéric
bebédé le parquet ouvre une enquête
préliminaire et ce mardi
[Musique]
le becbéd était convoqué au commissariat
de police il est placé en garde àue qui
est la règle entre guillemets la règle
du jeu là où ça se complique un peu
c'est que la victime est une de ces
relations c'est-à-dire qu'il avait une
relation habituelle avec cette jeune
fille al je sais pas ça durait pas
depuis des années puisqu'elle a 17 ans
on peut discuter du fait qu'elle est 17
ans mais elle est
majeure pas enfin elle est elle la
majorité
sexuelle après on ne juge pas la morale
en
France on y viendra peut-être un jour
mais en tout cas pour l'instant on juge
pas encore la morale donc cette jeune
fille et sa petite amie entre guillemets
enfin une de ses enfin sa
maîtresse ils ont passé la nuit ensemble
dans un hôtel à peau ils ont eu une
relation intime à un moment donné dans
cette chambre d'hôtel et elle était
consentante en revanche il a voulu
euh réitérer
son l'acte et du coup elle était plus
consentante et elle prétend elle a
affirme qu'il qu'il l'a violé de de
façon digitale bon euh
quoi c'est c'est quand même une une
ambiance un peu compliquée un peu
complexe euh évidemment si elle ne
voulait pas avoir cette deuxième
relation sexuelle c'est tout à fait son
droit et si il l'a forcé effectivement
il y a viol mais là je souhaite bon
courage aux enquêteurs aux magistrat
instructeurs pour démêler le vrai du
faux parce que lui conteste farouchement
les faits euh donc là dans ces cas-là
c'est comme souvent la parole de l'un
contre la parole de l'autre et on va
croire qui CR contre cramer non mais on
croit qui euh on croit euh on croit bbéd
on croit cette jeune fille c'est
extrêmement compliqué il y a pas de il y
a pas de comment dirais-je de euh de de
de preuve scientifique d'ADN de de de
choses comme ça ils sont ensemble dans
la même chambre d'hôtel effectivement il
y a sûrement de l'ADN partout des deux
euh donc en en terme de police techn
scientifique il y a rien en terme de
téléphonie il y a rien donc c'est pas il
s'était revu entre cet été et maintenant
ou pas du tout alors ça je je n'ai pas
cette information je vous rappelle il
étaprès g non on sait pas on sait pas
non non on sait pas c'est en garde à vue
depuis depuis depuis ce matin donc alors
la garde à vue a été élevée ce qui est
plutôt bon signe c'estd que les
policiers lui ont posé les questions
qu'il considérait devoir lui poser et
ils l'ont remis en liberté à ma
connaissance il n'est pas m en examen
donc qui a pas été déféré devant un juge
d'instruction ce qui ne veut pas dire
que l'enquête s'arrête à ce stade elle
va certainement se poursuivre il y a des
investigations à mener elles vont être
menées mais aujourd'hui Frédéric bbéé ni
totalement les faits et cette jeune
femme affirme cette jeune fille affirme
que qu'il a eu viol voilà c peut-être
juste une une précision euh on en parle
parfois mais c'est pas parce queil y a
eu un rapport sexuel consenti je je je
dém pas ce que vous avez dit mais je
voudrais appuyer il peut très bien avoir
un premier rapport sexuel consenti et un
deuxè forcé et c'est ça reste un viol ça
peut être un viol va Rapp qui nous
rejoignent c'est ça c'est l'absence de
consentement rappele parce qu'il y a eu
un premier oui il y a eu un premier
rapport sexuel consenti là tout le monde
est d'accord il peut non non mais je
déms pas j'ai dit exactement la même
chose je suis complètement d'accord avec
vous SAF
que
oui bien sûr non mais c'est pour aussi
c'est pour aussi les téléspectateurs ça
c'est pas parce qu'il y a un premier
rapport c'est pas parce qu'on fait
l'amour une première fois qu'une
deuxième fois on peut se passer de
consentement et je rappelle que même
dans un couple l'absence de consentement
c'est un viol he voilà viol conjugal et
on parlait de pénétration digitale c'est
aussi un viol he toute forme de
pénétration est un VI dit alors voilà ce
sera une pénétration digitale qui est un
viol ça il faut le dire aussi alors
c'est vrai qu'il ni et son avocat a même
demandé en garde à vue des actes
d'enquête complémentaires alors ça c'est
un peu pour retourner la situation mais
il a tout à fait le droit c'estàdire
qu'il va demander je pense y y a-t-il
des expertises médicales parce que c'est
peut-être le point faible est-ce qu'il
peut y avoir une confrontation est-ce
que le dossier peut avancer comme ça
pour le moment il est pas mis en examen
mais l'enquête préliminaire se poursuit
donc sur le déroulé des faits et sur la
manière dont ça se terminera pour le
moment on ne peut absolument rien dire
voilà le témoin témignage le témoignage
et la plainte de cette jeune femme ont
paru suffisamment crédiible pour que une
enquête soit ouverte voil alors donc ce
serait déroulé dans une chambre d'hôtel
la garde à vue été levé en fin
d'après-midi Absolum alors juste pour
dire l'hôtel dans lequel ça se serait
passé et bien connu de Frédéric beckbud
puisque c'est un hôtel dont je crois il
a été lui-même actionnaire pendant
plusieurs années exactement la ville l
naavar donc il a été actionnaire je
crois de 2011 à 2015 voilà donc il
connait l'endroit ce qui préje rien
également voilà la garde à vue bah voilà
il s'est exprimé et encore une fois pour
que son avocat demande des actes
complémentaires c'est une manière de
entre guillemets selon la défense de
Frédéric bebedé potentiellement frag
fragiliser le témoignage de la plignante
en disant nous allons contre-attaquer
voilà j'ajoute quand même que le fait
que la garde à vue até levée que il nit
pas été ni mis en examen ni comme témoin
assisté laisse entendre quand même la
fragilité de l'accusation oui vous
vouliz rajouter quelque chose et
l'impossibilité d'établir des preuves
donc par ver ça on verra ça va être oua
ça va être compliqué et franchement j'ai
toujours connu Frédéric entouré j'ai
jamais de problème de pour séduire ou
pour avoir les les plus belles filles du
monde à ses pieds ou c'est une rock donc
c'est une rockstar franchement donc
est-ce qu'il a besoin
deé pas besoin de forcer quoi ça fait
toujours penser au voisin qui a tué 40
personnes dans l'immeuble et quand tu
interview les gens bah il était super
gentil jamais eu d'histoire avec lui ça
fait toujours penser à ces histoires là
c'est bizarre c'est à chaque fois qu'il
y a des histoires comme ça il y a des
gens qui viennent oui mais vous
inquiétez pas tout va bien mais ça veut
dire qu'on connais jamais les gens on
connait jamais les gens tu l'as ditas
dit ce que je voulais dire on peut pas
connaître les gens à 100 % peutêtre 99
c'est ressenti après oui c'est le
ressenti deéta pas ni sous lit j'ai pas
mis de caméra auudessus je sais pas sais
bien voilà non mais c'est c'est oui non
mais en fait moi je pensais aussi que la
fille elle est jeune mais est parents 17
ans elle est mineure ouis c'est pas la
fille qui alors à ce momentl si vous
parlez des par est Maur
sexu pourquoi tu vas chercher une
17 c'est pas la
questionour avec une petite de 17
ans il a 58 ans il veut faire l'amour
avec une petite de 17 ans et ben c'est
qu'il a de bases des problèmes
psychologiques je suis désolé mais ça je
vous dis pas le contraire on juge pas la
morale on peut dire quand même on ne
juge pas la morale dans ce
pays ils avaient une relation depuis
plusieurs mois qui était et ben on n pas
c relation là quand on a C là déjà
deêtes pas vous êtes pas le le juge
de de sa moralité il fait ce qu'il veut
la vraie question c'est est-ce qu'il y a
eu viol ou pas viol après qui qui
dorment avec une jeune fille qui couche
avec une fille de 17 an vous choqueer ça
je je fille est peutêtre aussi très JEE
pour savoir ce qu'elle a vraiment envie
de faire 17 ans c'est très jeune mais je
dis pas le
contraire veulent pas se mettre aussi
dans la merde qu'il arrêtent de
s'intéressé à des gamines voilà désolé
la morale
pas vous parlez de moral et on peut
comprendre comprendre que dit après la
loi là on parle par au point de vue la
loi a rien de réhensible si à part voilà
part s'il y a eu bien sûr non
consentement lors du deuxè rapport c'est
ça qui pose
problème mais mais sinon ça c'est de
l'ordre de la morale Kelly et voilà
c'est c'est 58 ans 17 ans on peut on
peut rien dire voilà après on dit sil
font ce qu'ils veulent si c'est une
histoire d'amour qu'ils ont envie de
vivre bon après c'est vrai que c'est
voilà c'est y a un gros écart mais bon
les investigations qu'ils vont qui vont
être menés maintenant c'est essayer de
savoir s'il y a eu un différent entre
eux qui justifierait qu'elleit déposer
cette plainte oui parce que c'est ça qui
pose question qui donne plutôt je trouve
du poids à la parole de la victime c'est
quel intérêt elle a à à à porter plainte
comme ça pour viol c'est on sait très
bien qu'un femme qui porte plainte c'est
un un tas d'EM merde qui
commence redouter affronter la parole
des policiers gognard et cetera même si
ça s'est amélioré la parole la famille
qu'est-ce que tu faisais avec lui et
cetera c'est beaucoup d'emmerde dont on
pourrait se passer aisément donc si elle
le fait c'est quand même qu'elle a une
bonne raison qu'elle pourrait être cette
raison bon du cou ça donne du poids à
son témoignage enfin à son mais je oui
Bono tu voulais dire non non je disais
en fait en t'écoutant je pensais aussi
aux parents quand tu as une fille de 17
ans c'est une fille qui est relativement
jeune bien sûr et euh et elle en a
sûrement parlé à ses parents enfin tu
vois ça ça compte aussi c'est c'est pas
une fille de 25 ans quoi c'est
exactement ouais c'est vraiment une
ouais bref quoi c'est ça c'est une fille
de 17 ans c'est vrai que c'est c'est à
prendre en compte c'est vrai que 17 ans
c'est c'est extrêmement
jeune il se singularise par ça mais
c'est ultra violant il va être
sanctionné il ris 2 ans de prison cy
bien
faitu comment vous pourez dire en
regardant en polonais g tu te trouves
très beau et très très
sensuel oh là
là j'ai un truc pas bien dit
mince mais tu as dit ce que je t'ai
demandé ouis peu
près estoulez qu' vous dis chacun quel
chose
ou qu'est-ce que tu voudrais qu'elle te
dis
euh alors un truc gentil tu as envie de
me dire ou un truc méchant méchant
ah je peux pas supporter ta
tronche voilà c'est mieux en polonais
qu'en français je trouve un truc gentil
ou méchant c'est bien un truc gentil ou
méchant tu veux non tu vfèes lui dire un
truc gentil ou méchant lui méchant
méchant méchant tu veux un truc méchant
estce que un truc méchant pourquoi tu
continues à avoir deux boulots tu as pas
assez d'argent c'est long ah c'est
méchant c'est long la dit al je sais pas
un truc méchant ben dislui traite-ele de
traite ouis moi une insulte comme si je
Tavais fait une queue de poisson en
voiture g ça veut dire quoi merde hein
une merde mer j'ai l'impression
[Rires]
que j'ai l'impression que c'est ça en
fait tu tu te s polonaise pour dire
exactement ce que tu penses des gens
ici qui qui veut oui tu m'excites non
mais gentil ou
méchant gentil ou méchant tu veux dire
pe dire méchant gentil ou méchant gentil
ou méchant lui est gentil ah ah il il a
la côte he tu m'excites mais je l'ai
déjà dit en fait bon agile non mais si
non mais si elle veut pas dire elle ve
pas dire c'est comme ça bah tu es mon
meilleur ami c'est nul c'est nul quoi
mon meilleur ami c'est pas Lori connard
je pas non mais c'est laisse tomber il
est nul Jean Michel truc un truc gentil
je préféis non non non elle a pas envie
tu veux dire méchant B euh je sais pas
tu es tu es tu es aussi con qu'une
tub pas mais c'est pas long Polska c'est
pas long tu as dit pas long c'est pas
long c'est pas long c'est pas long
Polska ouais mais bon ouais qu'est tu
j'ai pas dit tu sais pas dire to en
polonais
elle veut pas le dire ça veut pas dire
elle veut pas dire benï gentil ou
méchant gentil ah bien quoi ça va elle
aime que Valérie et Guillaume ouais
ouais non j'adore Gill ah en les autres
je vous aiment bien aussi non mais ça va
non te rattraperon rattrape pasas toutes
les filles qui sont làbas aent bien
Gill c'est vrai Ky adore
g adore g sors sors sors tu es
[Applaudissements]
con comment on dit en polonais tu es
vraiment plus tu es vraiment de plus en
plus
con CIS que c'est pour toi
oui ben euh bah tuas une belle rencontre
y bocot
env j'ai j'ai un trou pas grave pas
grave moi bah j'ai un trou comme on
ditour Mamour oua tu crois que ça va te
servir ça il y a moyen que ça serve en
Pologne j'ai un trou merci en tout cas
voulez que je vous dise c'est une très
belle séquence vraiment j'ai trouvé
queéit une très belle squence d'amour et
d'amitié qu'est-ce qu'il y a elle pas
dit elle a pas dit quelque chose à vous
enou méchantou
méé monsieur est audessus de tout le
monde moi je suis le chef va venir
quel on verra gentil ou méchant
vas-y c'est pas c'est pas évident tu
crois j'ai le temps conneries un truc
méchant c un peu truc méchant vas-y
chois vas-y à [__] moi non dis-moi je
te traduis
choisiris mais je vais te virer ou pas
non
is
[Applaudissements]
merme on a le même mot ça l'air pire que
ça c'est un vrai ba je pense c'est c'est
un vrai ba tu du gland mais elle est
folle mais attends mais c'est
une rig ça h on peut pas le dire est-ce
que tu peux dire ce qu'elle a
dit que peux dire en allemand
gre mais pour vous avez dit ça mais il
vous a dit
quoiom c'est vra c'est
vraiement fol
vous non franchement je pense qu'elle
va on s'en fout allez on passe
c'est dégradant pour vous bah bah quand
même les téléspectateurs attends vous
vous attendiez un truc comme ça ou pas
du tout pas du tout pas du tout mais
est-ce que c'est vrai ou c'est une fake
news non c'est une fake news je sais pas
c'est pas grave alors si c'est une fake
news Pasino les tpect au moins on s'en
fout vous faut pas dire dire en privé
vra ah ouais vous êtes heurté ah quoi
vous êtes heurté lui heuré franchement
c'est un truc de fou je vous jure même
pas dire au téléspectateur je sais même
pas comment elle a pensé à ça
voilà c'est une ex copine à moi qui date
de 2017 Julie on sa oui oui Julie on
s'est
fréquenté plusieurs fois d'accord voilà
c'est un peu compliqué c'est une
histoire qui part un peu dans dans tous
les sens médiatiquement
judiciairement d'accord mais voilà donc
je rappelle que vous avez témoigné
auprès de la justice donc vous avez été
entendu par la justice dans cette
affaire donc votre témoignage m entendu
va être pris en compte euh dans dans
l'affaire euh vous la connaissez donc
depuis 2017 c'est ça je la connais
depuis 2017 ma première rencontre avec
Julie c'est 2017 d'accord vous l'avez
connu comment je l'ai connu à l'émission
j'ai un ami dont je terrai le nom pour
l'enquête euh qui travaillait avec
Sébastien cé pendant de nombreuses
années euh cette cette fille venait euh
dans le
public moi j'ai assisté à plusieurs
émissions
je me suis rapproché moi personnellement
de de cette fille parce que je la
trouvais physiquement attirante voilà je
la trouvaé belle j'ai vu qu'elle avait
un tatouage de micro donc on il y a eu
une discussion très vite on a échangé
notre facebook voilà nos facebook j'ai
vu qu'elle
était très fanatique de de Sébastien cé
donc on en a parlé et ce jour-là elle
m'a
annoncé avoir pris une chambre de
d'hôtel donc on est en 2017 avoir pris
une chambre d'hôtel pour pour que cé
puisse la rejoindre derrière voilà à la
fin de l'émission à cette époque- làà cé
euh finissait les émissions vers 21h 22h
c'était un peu plus tard sur sur energie
et voilà elle me dit ce cé va venir me
rejoindre sur à l'hôtel j'ai pris une
chambre d'hôtel vousz-nous raconter
toute l'histoire parce que vous avez
entendu des truc de fou pourquoi vous
avez décidé de témoigner auprès de la
justice c'est vous qui avez demandé de
témoigner non ce n'est pas moi qui
demandé témoigner moi
j'ai j'ai suivi l'affaire de loin j'ai
plus de réseaux sociaux euh je suis
extérieur à tout ça j'ai des comptes qui
existent mais avec pas du tout d'amis et
je suis vraiment loin de tout ça et
c'est dans lors d'une soirée il y a pas
si longtemps que ça il y a à peu près un
mois un ami me dit Oh là tu as vu ce qui
se passe avec avec coé je me je regarde
sur les réseaux je vais sur google je
tape jqué et je vois une fille Julie il
y avait pas le nom hein le nom de
famille encore de Saint-Laurent sur
euh porte plainte pour viol je l'ai
reconnu direct et je l'ai appelé ah
d'accord vous appelé Julie vousmême je
l'ai appelé je l'ai appelé et donc et
donc et donc vous l'avez appelé je l'ai
appelé euh pour pour essayer d'en savoir
d'en savoir un peu plus parce qu'il faut
savoir que lors de de notre rencontre je
refais un petit point parce le il y a
pas eu de il y a pas eu de de Cé l''a
pas suivi du moins à la chambre d'hôtel
ce jour-là c'était c'était un enfin un
mytho qu'elle s'est inventé et tout
parce que c'est moi qui suis allé à
cette chambre d'hôtel euh il s'est passé
ce qui s'est passé on s'est rapproché
moi alors je dis pas que je suis tombé
amoureux mais je me suis accroché à
cette à cette fille je me suis assez
vite rendu compte que elle était là
uniquement pour pouvoir se rapprocher de
de koi voilà c'était vraiment une elle
était vraiment hystérique de de de CO
euh c'est ce que vous avez dit à la
justice c'est c'est en cours voilà tout
ce qui est à faire vraiment justice je
veux pas en parler parce qu'il y a une
enquête qui est lour je sais qu' il y a
une partie médiatique d' qui avance
beaucoup plus vite que la justice
maintenant tout ce qui est de l'ordre
judiciaire je ne peux pas voilà je vous
avez entendu vous avez ét entendu ou pas
j'ai une petite ça je peux pas je peux
pas répondre sur ce sujet là maintenant
je sais que les preuves et je remets la
petite parenthèse que je voulais dire
tous les enregistrements dernièrement
quand j'ai pris contact avec elle tous
les toutes les conversations ont été
enregistrées j'ai fait des captures
d'écran des enregistr ement audio voilà
parce que j'ai des pourquoi vous avez
fait ça pour pourquoi j'ai fait ça parce
que je sais très bien qu'elle ment c'est
un stratagème qu'elle a monté avec
plusieurs personnes c'est depuis déjà
2017 elle en parlait c'était quoi ce
stratagème pour vous ce stratagème c'est
il y a il y a un aspect extrêmement
financier derrière tout ça c'est juste
une histoire d'argent voilà c'est ce que
je r compte et un histoire d'ego un
histoire d'ego elle est jalouse maladive
je pense que j'ai vu he l'émission de de
moi je la connais je l'ai jamais
rencontré je l'ai jamais vu natthalie
d'tois parce que cé n'était pas voilà la
femme de la femme de de Cé je me suis du
moment où il a annoncé son couple elle a
été extrêmement jalouse voilà
extrêmement jalouse de sa situation donc
il a un ego mais il faut savoir que je
ne peux pas donner de nom çaessortira un
jour tout ce que je dis mais ça ne vient
pas forcément d'elle elle il n'y a pas
que elle voilà à savoir qu'elle a posé
parce qu'elle l'a fait avec Sébastien cé
mais je sais aussi et j'en ai les
preuves elle l'a fait avec d'autres
personnes elle a déposé plainte aussi
contre d'autres d'autres personnes pour
viol voilà des personnes qui ont de
l'argent d'accord euh qu'est-ce que vous
lui avez dit quand vous l'avez appelé
dernièrement parce que vous vous avez
dit que vous l'aviez appelé alors moi
j'ai joué la carte euh de rentrer dans
son jeu de dire c'est bien ce que tu as
fait et tout moi je voulais absolument
euh bah qu'elle crache le Mor morceau
mon but c'était de contacter ça a été
compliqué ça a été difficile mais de
contacter Sébastien cé parce que je suis
pas un fanatique de Cé mais c'est
quelqu'un qui m'a toujours touché quand
j'allais à ses émissions c'est quelqu'un
qui m'a extrêmement touché parce qu'il
est parti de rien tout ce qu'il a
construit il a construit jeune tout seul
et sans lidre de personne donc lui
flinguer parce qu'il y a pas d'autres
mot sa carrière à cet Hommel j'ai trouvé
ça extrêmement dégueulasse donc là
j'étais entre deux parties il y a ma
donc vous êtes dit même si vous
connaissiez pas coé personnellement vous
vous êtes dit je vais essayer de de de
de un peu de de d' voilà de d'intervenir
dans cette affaire essayer d'avoir des
informations c'est ça voilà j'ai bah moi
j'ai voulu essayer de bah j'ai envoyé
déjà un premier message à des
connaissances de de coé des des
personnes qui ont qui ont eu travailler
avec lui en tant que stagiaire et de fil
en aiguille j'ai pu une une personne
travaillant avec m'a rappelé une
personne proche de couré pour avoir des
informations à ce moment-là euh on m'a
demandé de de de savoir si je pouvais en
avoir plus plus d'informations et c'est
ce que j'ai fait donc c'est pour ça que
j'ai prêché le faux pour avoir le vrai
de rentrer en contact avec Julie ainsi
que d'autres personnes parce qu'il y a
d'autres personnes c'est pour ça qu'on
appelle bien de la bande organisée il y
a d'autres personnes euh qui sont là bah
pour le pour le nuire et lu piquer l' ça
s'est pas passé du tout comme prévu
qu'est-ce qu'elle vous a dit quand vous
l'avez eu au téléphone par que vous
l'avez eu le jour où elle est venue ici
d'ailleurs elle était dans le train elle
était dans le train la première fois que
je l'ai eu au téléphone elle était en
route le premier jour où elle est venue
donc masqué avec sa capuche ici euh et
je lui fais avouer très vite euh je lui
fais avouer très vite le le fait que il
y a de l'argent qu'il y a de l'argent à
la clé voilà je rentre dans son jeu je
lui dis tu sais en parlant d'elle et
d'autres personnes ils sont prêts à tout
pour te faire tomber si tu veux que je
fasse partie du pour t'aider du
stratagème je je peu et elle m'a répondu
c'est clair je vais tout donner voilà
maintenant je ne rentrerai pas plus dans
les dans les détails des conversations
vous dites vous avez dit apparemment
dit que elle voulait le faire tomber
depuis 2017 depuis 2017 elle en parle
elle dit quoi depuis 2017 elle elle veut
mettre en place je dis bien avec
d'autres personnes parce que elle n'est
pas toute seule et il est prévu de faire
tomber de faire tomber co voilà mais
c'est quoi le plan de base alors ouais
agression sexuelle viol donc quoi pour
prendre
pourextorion de fond selon vous voilà il
y a une rumeur qu'elle m'a sorti un jour
comme quoi c'est facile de de mettre des
messages sur les réseaux
sociaux les avocats des personnes
connues appellent très vite pour faire
effacer contre de l'argent donc ça a été
son
but sauf que ça s'est pas passé comme
prévu après monsieur vous êtes pas sans
savoir que elle n'est pas la seule avoir
pé plainte elle n'est pas la seule à
avoir porté plainte et les autres il y a
pas de problème d'extorsion et de les
autres je les connais les autres
personnes je les alors est-ce que je les
connais tous je n'en sais rien
maintenant avec le temps je sais qu'il y
avait d'autres person il y a trois
plaintes donc il y a Julie qui qui a
déposé plainte mais il y a aussi deux
autres plaintes dont une plainte pour
viol et agression sexuelle même si
l'agression sexuelle dans ce cas-là je
crois que c'est prescrit dans cette
deuxième plainte et donc là donc dans ce
cas-là vous avez rien à dire sur ces
deux autres plainte on est d'accord vous
vous parlez que du cas de Julie je parle
du cas de Julie parce que j'ai des
preuves qui sont concrètes les autres
personnes je dis pas que je ne les
connais pas je dis juste que je ne veux
pas en parler parce que c'est
extrêmement grave ce que vous dites ce
soirire c'est un c'est un témoignage clé
c'est pour ça que je vous ai demandé et
que je sais que vous avez été entendu
mine de rien euh vous avez été entendu
par et vous allez être entendu encore
par la justice parce que forcément on
peut pas faire des des des des
affirmations comme ça et affirmer des
choses comme ça sans être entendu
derrière par la justice parce que c'est
quand même clé dans dans l'affaire bien
sûr c'est c'est clé pour la plainte de
Sébastien cet qui est cette plainte pour
donc tentative d'extorsion de fond et
moi je voulais savoir est-ce qu'il a
déposé plainte parce que vous lui avez
apporté des éléments est-ce que c'est à
la avec votre témoignage les éléments
que vous apportez que Sébastien cohet a
déposé cette plainte pour extorsion
alors je suis pas à la place de de
Sébastien je ne suis pas à la place de
Sébastien
cé je d'ailleurs je lui ai même pas
parlé une seule fois je pense qu'il est
très prudent je suis rentré en contact
avec des personnes autour qui qui qui
sont de confiance je pense d'ailleurs
que je ne connais pas mais non non non
lui je sais de toute manière
pertinemment qu'il est pour le cas de
Julie hein du moins qu'il est innocent
donc il a porté plainte avant moi je lui
ai amené les élé pardonnez-moi monsieur
mais vous dites je sais pertinemment
qu'il est innocent on ne préjuge en rien
de l'affaire d'abord on ne command pas
cette une affaire en cours et le
témoignage d'une d'une jeune femme vous
ne savez rien si ce n'est que peut-être
il y aurait une tentative d'extorsion
mais rien l'un n'empêcherait
éventuellement pas l'autre donc vous ne
pouvez pas dire aujourd'hui de façon
affirmative comme ça et péremptoire je
sais que vous savez un élément d'un
dossier qui est extrêmement visiblement
complexe et un bout du caléidoscope
éventuellement pour l'instant il y a que
Julie où ça son identité est révélé
c'est pour ça qu'aujourd'hui je parle de
Julie parce que j'ai j'ai très bien
connu Julie maintenant les autres
personnes je n'en parlerai pas mais vous
pensez les connaître je ne répondrai pas
à cette question je ne peux pas il y a
il y a une justice qui est en cours je
sais très bien que je sais très bien qu'
qu'il y a les médias dessus mais il y a
aussi une justice et il faut faire
confiance ass à la justice dans cette
affaire mais pardon monsieur qu'est-ce
qui vous pousse aujourd'hui à prendre la
parole et à raconter ce que vous dites
je l'ai je l'ai expliqué savez c'est
quoi votre moteur mon moteur il y a
alors je on m'a posé la question bien
entendu savoir s'il y avait pas un
intérêt financier derrière si je peux
l'assurer que non si c'est dans ce
sens-l que vous voulez aller c'est
uniquement parce que je trouve ça
dégueulasse la façon d'avoir fait tomber
voilà c'est tout il y a pas non plus de
vengeance envers Julie euh elle a foutu
aussi le le bordel dans mon dans mon
couple alors justement parce que moi je
peux vous dire aussi non mais je peux
vous dire aussi vous aussi vous étiez
très amoureux duulit et vous essayez de
vous venger deulit ce que je peux dire
aussi voilà on peut se dire ça
aujourd'hui de lui nu exactement parce
qu'on peut dire vous av dit que vous
aviez une aventure avec elle que vous
étiez amoureux d'elle que Julie
apparemment elle était amoureuse de
quelqu'un d'autre je vous dis toutes les
possibilités voilà même ce que ce que
les gens les gens se posent la même
question que moi ils disent peut-être
c'est une pour vous une manière de vous
venger de Julie parce que elle vous a
fait du mal et parce que vous êtes
encore peut-être amourux d'elle qui est
tout à fait votre droit et peut-être que
voilà vous êtes un un amoureux et
conduit voilà et que vous dites je vais
essayer de fragiliser J on vous a posé
cette question on me l'a on me l'a posé
et j'ai répondu je n'ai jamais été
amoureux de Julie ça a été très
vite maintenant il y a une affaire qui
est en cours je peux pas rentrer non
plus dans les détails on avait des amis
en commun on a des amis en commun qui
ont fait une
image très dure d'elle parce que il
s'est avéré que le monde est petit à ce
moment-là on habitait dans le même
village à côté de Macon voilà à cette
époque là alors donc parce que
aujourd'hui votre témoignage il est vous
vous rendez compte que si votre
témoignage il faut faut être sûr de vous
parce que vous rendez compte que devant
la justice ça va être un témoignage qui
va être clé et que si le témoignage
correspond pas
àé a des pruves exactement là c'est vrai
que là ça peut être extrêmement grave
aussi pour vous donc pourqu elle a
jamais été violé en fait tout ça c'est
c'est c'est la mythomanie c'est une
invention de sa part par par rapport à
déjà à coé par rapport à ce que j'en
sais oui et je reviens sur ce que je
disais je ne serais pas là si j'avais
pas des preuves concrètes c'est quoi vos
preuves cones oui pr c'est des
enregistrements audio avec son numéro de
de téléphone et des échanges de SMS
sachant que c'est des SMS moi j'ai un
iphone j'ai changé plusieurs fois
d'iPhone j'ai toujours le même clou il y
a eu il y a plus de 70000 messages 70000
en tout parce qu'il y a plusieurs
personnes je reviens il y a pas que
Julie 70000 messages dans cette histoire
dans cette histoire vous avez tout
fourni à à la justice à la police c'est
tout a été fourni ah d'accord vous avez
donc là oui donc vous avez tout four la
je suis pas là non non mais c'est
important qu'il le disent donc vous avez
tout fourni à la police tout à l'heure
vous l'aviez pas dit clairement donc
donc là la police a tous les
éléments je il y a une
ou par rapport à mes éléments à moi oui
maintenant est-ce qu'ils ont tous les
éléments de toute l'enquête je mess
parce que il y a y a deux affaires ou il
y a d'une part une affaire d'extorsion
de fouutre autre part l'ffire de viol
est-ce que vos preuves disculpe
cohé voilà de de parce que là npêche pas
l'aut une fois parce que Julie a écrit
je n'ai jamais été violé j'invente tout
ça ça je peux pas y répondre ok mais
est-ce qu'il est disculpé de de de de
pour moi oui vous oui pour moi oui par
rapport aux preuves que j'ai oui mais
pardonnez-moi monsieur mais moi ça me
semble toujours étonnant quand on
appelle quelqu'un qui a été une une
ex-maîtresse ou ou quelqu'un de très
proche en tout cas d'AV avoir le réflex
d'enregistrer la conversation pour
quelle raison vous avez quand vous avez
cette tu débarques excuse-moi excuse-mo
il a dit depuis le début ça il dit il
l'a dit tout à l'heure non mais les mecs
écoutez dit
excusez-moiour tour on [__] dans la
chououte non non je te le dis il a il a
fait exprès parce qu'il a dit qu'il
voulait aider cé et qu'il avait
l'inttention de piéger Julie pour c'est
ça oui oui tout simplement je suis
rentré dans son jeu donc donc vous
saviez qu'il y avait un jeu je savais
oui que je savais de toute manière avant
de l'appeler vous saviez qu'il y avait
un bah avant avant de la avant de
l'appeler de toute manière je j'avais
mis en place j'ai essayé de réfléchir un
peu bon je l'ai appelé quand même assez
assez vite et bah quand quand j'ai su
elle s'est douté de rien elle vous a
tout dit et elle s'est douté de
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
rien